never before had the private exchange of
british royals and their senior palace
staff been so exposed
texts and emails by meghan markle and
prince harry to their former press aide
have been published as part of mail on
sunday's case against the duchess at the
court of appeal they revealed fractures
among the royal family as meghan's
relationship with her father broke down
and pressure increased on harry to
contain thomas marco's communication
with the press
in one text to jason nauf megan writes
even after a week with his dad and
endlessly explaining the situation his
family seemed to forget the context she
continues by taking this form of action
i protect my husband from the constant
berating emails are supposed to be a
letters of pride private letters between
people but once you're in the public
domain in a court of law then it can
become excruciatingly embarrassing for
for those people that don't particularly
want these things aired i don't think
it's that particularly damaging or
problematic for the for prince charles
who was simply saying can't something be
done to stop this
constant story of megan and her father
appearing in the press emails to jason
canav also reveal the extent to which he
acted as a conduit to pass background
information from the couple to the
authors of their biography finding
freedom with megan sending a long list
of topics she wanted covered from
relationships with her half-siblings to
press stories she felt needed correcting
in one email the press secretary warned
against connecting megan's friends to
authors of finding freedom he wrote
being able to say hand on heart that we
did not facilitate access will be
important and in response prince harry
said i totally agree that we have to be
able to say that we didn't have anything
to do with it
megan has this week apologized to the
court for denying that mr knauf had
provided information to the authors
saying she had not remembered those
exchanges at the time
even though he said in a witness
statement they discussed the book on a
routine basis multiple times in person
and over email
judges will decide on this case at a
later date but it's in the court of
public opinion where this battle is also
being fought
milano vaseline rich sky news